economía en francés 24 me acompaña en el
estudio daniela blandón daniela muy
buenas noches y comenzamos con la nueva
líder económica de eeuu que dijo que va
a impulsar el millonario plan de
estímulos para fortalecer la economía
allí santiago buenas noches graves de
esta frase gastar más ahora y pagar
después esa es la fórmula para la
recuperación económica que propuso la
nominada a hacer la secretaria del
tesoro janet yellen ella defendió ante
el comité financiero del congreso ese
plan de estímulos gigantesco por 1,9
billones de dólares y dijo que si no se
aprueba habrá una recesión más larga y
dolorosa escuchemos la
el presidente electo ni yo propusimos
este paquete de alivios sin una
apreciación de la carga de la deuda del
país
pero ahora mismo con las tasas de
interés en mínimos históricos lo más
inteligente que podemos hacer es actuar
en grande a largo plazo creo que los
beneficios superarán con creces los
costos y cosas danielle hablemos ahora
de la unión europea que quiere
incentivar el uso mundial de su moneda
del euro si santiago presentó un plan
que busca hacerle frente a la hegemonía
mundial del dólar y proteger así a sus
países de frente a la crisis de divisas
o sanciones que les impongan de hecho la
comisión europea dice que se quiere
blindar de un panorama muy beligerante
haciendo alusión muy seguramente a la
guerra comercial que estaría a punto de
comenzar con eeuu el euro santiago es la
segunda divisa más usada del mundo
representa el 38 por ciento de los pagos
y una quinta parte de las reservas de
divisas pero las autoridades dicen que
hay un gran margen de mejora como parte
del plan de unión europea emitirá más
deuda en euros
buscará la unión de sus bolsas de
valores también seguirá explorando la
posibilidad por ahora bastante lejana de
lanzar un euro digital hablemos ahora
otra vez de eeuu el presidente saliente
de donald trump le dice adiós a la casa
blanca con más sanciones para venezuela
sí señor emitió varias sanciones contra
miembros de una red supuestamente
liderada por el empresario colombiano
álex up el objetivo de esta red según
washington era comercializar crudo
venezolano y evadir así las
penalizaciones que le impuso a la
estatal pedevesa en 2019 en un
comunicado la secretaria del tesoro
dice que la acción se dirige a
orquestadores y facilitadores que tienen
vínculos con una red en mexico y que a
su vez han conspirado con el ministro de
petróleos de maduro tareck al aissami y
alexa up para negociar la venta de
cientos de millones de dólares de
petróleo venezolano álex a up recordemos
es el supuesto testaferro de nicolás
maduro y está preso en cabo verde a la
espera de ser extraditado justamente a
eeuu para responder por lavado de dinero
y seguimos hablando de américa latina
chile inauguró este martes la primera
zona 5g de toda la región américa
latina' de qué se trata si el
experimento se hará sobre un área de 5.5
kilómetros cuadrados en santiago que
tiene hospitales comercios colegios y
oficinas entre otros la adopción de la
tecnología 5g permite aumentar
drásticamente la velocidad de la
conexión y la interfaz de los
dispositivos sin embargo también tiene
una mala noticia y es que en muchos
países ha sido el centro de debate
debido a cuestionamientos sobre la
ciberseguridad así como también el
manejo de los datos de la ministra de
comunicaciones de chile- habla del
impacto que tendrá esa nueva red en las
ciudades y cuando vemos un drone que es
capaz de detectar información de suelos
agrícolas y tomar decisiones y mandar
instrucciones de riego por ejemplo
cuando vemos que una cámara inteligente
con 5g detecta la cantidad de personas
que están esperando para cruzar un
semáforo en alameda como tenemos también
un experimento y automáticamente cambia
la luz para darle prioridad a los
peatones para que no se aglomeren
danielle hablemos de las bolsas como
cerraron los principales parques del
mundo es precisamente el respaldo de
janet yellen al plan de estímulos
impulsó las ganancias de hoy en wall
street y puso al nasdaq a cerca de un
nuevo récord
las bolsas europeas por su parte
cerraron a la baja todas muy cautelosas
y la expectativa de la toma de posesión
de joe biden las bolsas de américa
latina por su parte terminaron mixtas
hablemos ahora de la cifra del día para
el cierre los 200 millones de usuarios a
los que llego netflix a finales de 2020
tuvo resultados bastante buenos en el
último trimestre
daniela muchas gracias gastar más ahora
y pagar después muchas gracias sigan con
la programación de france 24